oui vous savez cet accord a été
renouvelé la semaine dernière pour
encore 60 jours mais le vice directeur
des ports d'Ukraine hier m'a dit qu'en
réalité de prix le bien avant sur
renouvellement la corne fonctionne pas
comme il devrait notamment le port de
PIF Denis qui est l'un des trois ports
dans la baie de dessin et en fait c'est
le port le plus profond et en quelque
sorte le plus important là les Russes ne
donnent pas du tout accès aux navires
depuis trois semaines ces navires
restent bloqué dans les eaux Turcs à
l'entrée de la mer Noire les deux autres
ports donc au dessin même et turnomors
que continue de fonctionner mais au
rythme ralenti si avant il pouvait
inspecter 12 navires par jour maintenant
c'est trois seulement donc ils ont
réduit d'un facteur de 4 la vitesse de
leurs inspections les Russes selon les
ukrainiens et les Russes font cela
exprès
et il se demande comment l'accord peut
continuer de fonctionner dans ces
circonstances bien sûr l'option reste
ouverte aux Ukrainiens comme ils l'ont
fait une fois avant avec l'accord de la
Turquie de tout simplement
laisser les navires passer dire que
qu'ils sortent de l'accord et en quelque
sorte terroriste que si vous voulez
tirer sur les navires allez-y mais
évidemment c'est un très très grand
risque à prendre et ce n'est pas
vraiment l'option qu'il voudrait prendre
pour le moment
Gulliver qu'est-ce que les Russes
cherchent à faire en menant ses blocages
c'est justement la question c'est sûr
que il ralentissent pas pour des raisons
techniques mais pour mettre la pression
les Ukrainiens ici au dessin en tout cas
disent que il ne savent pas exactement
les détails des réclamations des Russes
je vous rappelle que l'Ukraine ne
négocie pas directement avec la Russie
sur cet accord mais avec l'intermédiaire
de la Turquie et des Nations Unies mais
on sait que la Russie aimerait avoir un
meilleur accès au système Swift pour les
transferts bancaires pour les paiements
pour les engrais notamment pour
faciliter ces exportations d'engrais
dis-moi ça c'est quelque chose que la
Russie a évoqué publiquement il y a très
probablement d'autres réclamations que
la Russie n'évoque pas publiquement et
qui ont peut-être avoir avec la guerre
il se peut aussi que la Russie prépare
le terrain pour la visite le mois
prochain d'une délégation de six
présidents africains qui doivent se
rendre à Moscou et à Kiev pour parler
notamment de cet accord peut-être qu'il
git de montrer qu'il y a un problème
pour mettre la pression pour que des
solutions soient trouvées des solutions
qui prendraient la forme pour les Russes
de concession envers la Russie en
matière de sanction